nominated actor who's been called a
monster Talent direct quote and
Unstoppable and Unstoppable phenomenon
right so direct quote you may recognize
Jesse Buckley from shows and movies such
as Fargo and Judy and the lost daughter
which was particularly beautiful
it was her stunning performance in the
Lost daughter that earned her an Oscar
nomination
is that about Casey Anthony her latest
project is the movie women talking oh no
that is no who said was it frozen that
sent us you piece of [ __ ] women talking
that might be so it's a horror movie
is it a blumhouse flick a24
this is the if you're trying to get
people to see this
I can't think of a worse title
than women talking what is the movie
about about my wife every time I'm about
to go to sleep yeah wait I'm gonna get
paid 25 bucks to go to an IMAX and get
waterboarded no [ __ ] [ __ ] two
hours I'll pass look I work for the porn
parody women suck it to come out how's
that
it's about a group of Mennonite women
who break their Silence about abuse by
the men in their Ultra religious group
you might as well call this movie if you
come to the theater and buy a ticket
we're gonna smash your hands with
hammers and you go that's the name of
the movie or something I don't know
well I love I love local Cinema too
please
[Laughter]
oh
Buckley plays a young mother about that
it was a biop about the view it's all
Twitter women talking the story of The
View who is worried about what could
happen that's what the view should be
called women clocking women clocking
women babbling all day
worried about what could happen if their
secret is exposed take a look you're
exposing the goddamn business
you saw him JF drop the Cornet bomb that
was funny that was really important oh
disco too yeah I want to stay and fight
is this one [ __ ] what is this I
don't know let the dude fight that's
like bubbles
we gotta shave the [ __ ] kitties
that's the way he goes he says
don't we lose the fight to the men and
be forced to forgive them anyway so it's
wow it's Mormon women talking bro this
is one of those movies that's probably
adapted from a play so it's like
probably two sets and it's mostly just
people just there's not going to be no
action in this that's for sure what if
they've just made the perfect thing if
you can't sleep how about Mike might be
perfect how about Michael Bay's women
[ __ ] can we do that one I'll watch
that it's just girls scissoring going
ass to ass with a dildo and then Miami
mansion's blowing up for no reason I
will watch that right now
I want to stay and fight too no one
surprises imagine pitching this movie to
Michael Bay
pitched this movie to Michael Bay and
he's like all right but we need more
speed boats and we're like this is about
like 1800s Mennonite women speed boats
are almost
try to get Brett Ratner at this short
notice
all you do is fight
is this really how we are to decide the
fates of all the women in this colony
and just another vote where we put an X
next to our position I thought we were
here to do more than that is this a clip
that you're this is I'm gonna get a
copyright on Rumble since you play the
whole movie are they gonna like no
forget about how long it is right
are they gonna get to a point
what's going on the clip is supposed to
be this is the cell look at that scene
and it's like whoa when does a
Terminator show up because that's what I
need at this point dude if you close the
barn door and throw a torch in
but you remember like Arnold was burning
Arnold would go on The Tonight Show and
be like oh
here's a clip and it was like him
climbing on the back of the nitrogen
truck and the [ __ ] you know him
fighting the T-1000 for like a couple
seconds and then just as it looked like
he was gonna fall off the truck and cut
out and they'd be like wow I gotta go
see this or like in a funny movie when
they have like one quick 15 second
dialogue that was funny and it's like
two people you liked and you went oh man
I gotta go see this this is when women
going we must fight
to do with our Colony whipkey says the
religion should be called men are right
[Laughter]
okay I would say
the CNN with a guy coming over going you
ladies were talking now were you oh no I
hope you wasn't a talking and they're
like no sir
that's a pattern start looking at their
feet and [ __ ] yeah you're right
and they start talking more Charities
and they immediately start ratting each
other out right away as soon as the guy
shows up
she said it was like for sure
Rebecca she was trying to start some
kind of women's Union and I was like you
better not I'm not me I love being a
just a housewife that's great for me
everything else is insane
so women are really just going to be
doing this big suit thing now right like
this is like the fifth time we've had a
woman wearing a ridiculously big suit
they just don't care anymore also
um that's an action that's a famous
actress no one said famous
we saw the other thing she was on they
said she'd get nominated for an Oscar
yeah oh wow oh an Oscar I know it's a
2020 Oscar 2022 oscar but that's still
something is it the new ones are made
out of chocolate you get a few hundred
for it at a pawn shop
remember when actresses were hot yeah
they wouldn't take this chick home from
a bar no no she is a dumpy Broad
and Jesse Buckley and honestly it's even
if she were if she were to try me you
know
let the hair grow a little bit no
nothing okay that's just now to talk
about this amazing performance is it
because she's white
what
[Laughter]
I love white [ __ ]
I was saying I guess she's not Jewish
an amazing movie uh the scene doesn't
want to make lumos he doesn't want to
make Loomer jealous
we just saw you're in a hay loft I think
and the women of the community are
talking about what to do I remember that
song hey love
hey Loft
to uh to stay and fight the man now that
they've discovered this uh to leave the
community or to do nothing where did he
get that [ __ ] tie the Steve Vai
collection dude yeah that Ty's weird
right and they argue the points back and
forth when you read this script the new
NXT logo honestly this looks like Dave
this looks like that's pretty good this
looks like Dave Rubin said it really
does yeah it's cheap I understand it you
did not think it could be made that [ __ ]
on his tie but it was either that or
piano key I don't have any choices
I just had never read it is like Dave
rubin's Studio it's cheap looking and
filled with [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that's really good [ __ ]
it's really good oops like that I'd
never let your Frozen counting every
time you say it he's not here 17.
where it was predominantly female
characters oh so she's like in England
seven
oh yeah okay oh yeah absolutely she is
rough huh that is a rough looking
brighter these little lady eyes I feel
like I'm watching the undateables should
[ __ ] Pete Davidson's eyes
and where this can be Davidson's acting
rage apparently what kind of
conversation was taking place he's gonna
be the queen of Staten Island it's gonna
be great
it's where I can't wait for them to
blame this movie's failure on men yeah
you named it Norm Macdonald I'm going to
tell you right now I would have a field
day with this movie by the way just with
the title of it
you know so they should change it from
women talking to men not going
that is that would be the norm line no
you know this kind of Conquest to
imagine something more yeah this week uh
film women talking debut uh it made a
disappointing three million dollars this
weekend uh the number one movie uh of
the week was robots killing other robots
made like 500 million oh
and before you get mad a woman wrote
that joke just kidding we don't allow
women to work here
God I miss Norm yeah
it's understood about yourself and um
yeah so it took me I was like I don't
know dogging bobbed at the box office
this weekend uh looks like they
shouldn't have had a women riding either
that's a good one that was a good one
[ __ ]
we tried hard on spaying and neutering
animals are probably the worst thing you
can do uh cut your claws off your [ __ ]
that yes agreed I do not declaw cats
it's [ __ ] terrible
um uh sever saying that the uh the film
women talking uh it was a second title
uh the original title was slow torture